yeah don't move to the position I was
going to move to you and because you
just know that's what I'm gonna do go
walk out I'll walk out
[Music]
like a Sharpie listen
sharp and listen I said shut up say the
same thing week in week out about Nitty
Gritty juicy with sharp the question is
what lies do you tell yourself when your
heart's been broken
heart's been broken I got lows I'm just
gonna reel okay Daddy spill for me list
Spiel for me Daddy he loves me and she's
just the face
[Laughter]
wow wow he loves me and she's just a
phase he'll come back that's disgusting
yeah that's have some self-respect
Twisted Jesus next that I will move on
soon I haven't dated in three and a half
years next
she was uglier than oh she was ugly than
you thought bro the homies tried to tell
you but you didn't listen
damn
what do you mean the homies tried to
tell you he's talking in third person
yeah I know but still would you
homie's trying to say that your girl's
Butters not necessary it might not have
been his girl his heart was just broken
it was broken yeah she might have just
got someone else that's probably yeah it
was never his goal yeah it was his cross
his Crush moved on to someone else and
he was like yeah yeah
anyway bro I'm bigger than the guy she
cheated on me with
yeah that's a lie
it's always a lie it always is I'll lose
weight and make a comeback like a baddie
Michael said that's a lie I told myself
oh
the other hoes need me more
this man said I can't even lie to myself
anymore I've been empty inside yeah
they're just joking nah bro that's
hilarious love it man ah God will screw
him over in the end oh okay stop with
that now I can get back to revising
oh that's painful she's got to be gay
okay
he hurt me but he hurt me so obviously
he still has feelings he choose because
he chose to hurt me because he cared
enough to hurt me if he didn't care he
wouldn't do anything he would ignore me
he hurt me but he hurt me
wow that is crazy that's indeed that's
like Joe from you that's that kind of
crazy God yeah Jesus Christ yeah
Karma will come back and get them
all right he didn't mean it he just
chose to lie because he can't
communicate
I share everything with my best friends
anyway
okay that's dark that's really really
dark yeah yeah he banged your brethren
had to sit all the participants down and
like talk to me what like why why he
banged the bridge and said I shared with
her anyway so it's fine why man
I know he's I know he's having sex
moaning my name
that is a lie that is a lie that's a
lilac huge lie
I know he's looking up at the sun
wondering if I'm looking at it at the
same time
hahaha shut up
toys before boys
he didn't ghost me he probably just got
arrested
call calories don't count when I'm
hurting this much
fantastic period chat I've heard that
bear times calories don't count when I'm
at home I think this much
mad that's crazy I'm never going to do
wife activities on girlfriend salary
ever again
so you know she's lying on girlfriend's
salary yeah
what's girlfriend's salary who knows
he's just not paying you enough he who
knows
um
he loves me but he just doesn't know how
to love me
his mother did a poor job raising his
ass anyway yeah that that is alive her
performance sharp men don't cry until I
remember that Jesus wept
[Laughter]
nah bro yo I was in search of that one
that was send me
Jesus wept oh God that's funny oh God at
my last but not least my pronouns are me
myself and I ah Jesus Oh damn heartbreak
here has you doing the most on the Rope
sprawl literally on the robes everyone's
been heartbroken the thing is I don't on
the right yeah when I'm heartbroken
I don't tell myself any I don't have
coping mechanisms I don't tell myself
Any Lies bro okay I blame myself
entirely I think about things I should
have done better literally and I'm just
I'm in fatal yeah yeah fetal's right and
I'm ordering food I'm not leaving and I
don't want anyone to disturb me bro when
I'm when I'm heartbroken
I can't believe that deliveroo don't
have a spare key to my yard I'm not
getting up I'm not getting up I mean my
dressing gown and I've got my eye blinds
on everything to block everything I hate
sunlight oh I hate summer and I just
want to find companions who are going
through it too [__] I can't say the
worst if I was heartbroken I promise you
you can't ever tell me you're doing
something with your girlfriend
if you're posting at Alton Towers yeah I
was assuming you forgot to invite me
yeah yeah yeah and you went by yourself
because it can't be with my God you
can't be with your girl because I
couldn't do that to you you wouldn't
dare you wouldn't dare and she's a
cheating a liar as well not on the
ground never wow everyone needs to be
heartbroken facts facts tell me that
they're all trash bro being heartbroken
is
I don't think there's a lower feeling
that oh it's it reads it really feels
like someone just took something out of
your chest literally listening my heart
away give it back bro you can't and then
worst I've only really been heartbroken
like one time yeah and it was like for
like three days yeah thank God it sucked
and then I remember I remember trying to
trying to rush move on to the next thing
yeah and I was I was in there okay in
the next thing and I wanted to be like I
can't I I nearly had a breakdown oh no
and I was like you're nothing I was
thinking disco you're nothing compared
to her empty voids bro I was trying to
fill a hole with this
obviously I finished but yeah yeah
yeah I'm only a man but bro afterwards I
was like wow I didn't want to hear a
voice damn after I finish I don't want
to hear a voice I just want my girl
[Music]
you're not even on her Instagram story
you're on her Brethren's Instagram story
that you follow and you just see her in
the background having fun the most fun
just having fun she's never looked pink
she hasn't looked more tinted in her
life it's oh bro it's literally to us
and you want to be like you want to mess
it up why are you torturing me like this
why are you doing yeah like this is
soul-wrenching yeah bro how dare my
knees big man if I stop you you just
what is this thing under here by the way
there's a little yeah yeah yeah the
little the little saliva thing the
attachment yeah there's a little gland
in here sometimes that if you if you oh
yeah if you yeah it's like it's like
snake venom yeah yeah exactly squirts
out it squirts I just watched your whole
stream my bad guys um
perspective someone else's Instagram
story and she he or she is just having
the time of their life
oh there's nothing worse than witnessing
that there is nothing there is nothing
worse I'm going to see your ex having
fun there's there is nothing worse than
having a witnessing your ex having fun
and when you tell yourself don't message
don't message and then you message and
she leaves you on red
oh you should have listened to yourself
don't message yeah wow why did I mess it
you're pathetic you are you're actually
pathetic damn bro it's tough it's tough
man heartbreak is yeah it's not
something I would prescribe to anyone
definitely on my worst enemy no but then
when you're over it you're like what's
wrong with me facts because I'm actually
bad as [__] and why was I feeling that
way facts you you always think that but
when you're in that hole that Heartbreak
Hotel yeah it that's a pocket you can't
escape fumes you you can't escape it bro
it can see we're only human it consumes
you but yeah welcome to the show guys
welcome to the show guys that's probably
the quickest igq we've ever done I had
to I would just like bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang I'm here for it bro so
guys welcome back you already know what
to do you really know what your boys
like and you I know you know what daddy
likes you to do he wants you to head
over to patreon.com shits and gigs and
contribute to the cult contribute to the
cult babies become one of the cult
babies indoctrinate yourself deep within
the cult babies for or Amiga three pound
a month 10p a day run the P to S and G
and digest years and years of content
hundreds of episodes over there
literally that are that are juicy wussy
as always and um yeah man jump in the
Discord chat make some friends
Discord is but there's a few thousand I
saw it the other day there's a few
thousands there's a few thousand man in
there just died
making friends doing link UPS drink cups
all the Lean cups drink cups yeah bro
that's good cups that could be you but
you chose not to thanks now it's time to
make the right decision it's never too
late to make the right decision so do
that and in the meantime subscribe to
the channel if you watch on YouTube yeah
man that's important subscribe to the
channel if you're watching on YouTube we
are steamrolling through we are so
please do us a solid subscribe to the
channel
like the video if you liked the video
chirps are taking in the comments if it
means something to you and if you are
listen on any of the Audio Apps follow
leave a nice review five stars is
preferable but do what you need to do
yeah
um and without any further Ado we're
jumping in early today with a dilemma
from firelord Flags let's get into it
dilemma
so I've been dealing with this guy for
about 15 years on and off shut the shut
up man yeah
I'm 30 so we met when I was 15 him 17.
recently we've been hanging out again
and it's been nothing too serious but we
but we are [__] sorry yeah yeah but
we've after the same movie yeah yeah
outside of him I have another thing I've
been getting intimate with who is also a
friend I've known for a while we'll get
back to him
my 15-year on and off Ting has started
back up sexually but it's not what I
remember it being he doesn't eat the box
to get the prize he eats it so he can
just stick his present in and while I
enjoy the present I want the damn prize
now the possible help me in this is that
I thought I'd be spending the rest of my
life with 15 year old guy or 15 years
guys sorry at some point everything
about us clicks except the sex I need
rounds lots of head and a bunch of nasty
[__] but 15 years can really only give
me 15 minutes
meanwhile
uh the friend I've been intimate with
lately is giving me prizes back to back
with a gift on the side with that lot
with the last way sorry give side to
side back to back with a gift on the
side that lasts way longer than 15
minutes is what I was trying to say okay
my question is do I speak to 15 years
about this do I open up the topic of a
woman's Pleasures with him or do I just
keep two BFS or little things on the
side I don't know if I should bring it
up please help this is an interesting
one because there's multiple
there's multiple Lanes on this one in
like my thought process okay
let me give a quick um yeah quick quick
synopsis gone
um dealing with this brother on and off
for 15 years she's currently now 30.
um nothing too serious outside of him
she's seen another thing who's also been
a friend for a while but she'll get back
to that the 15 years uh friendship the
sex is not where it used to be he
doesn't really eat her out he just eats
out to get a wet so he can bang and he
doesn't really make her come at all
um whereas the other guy is giving her
rounds giving her nuts yeah and giving
her a healthy amount of deep yeah should
she tell
boyfriend a
which is 15 years guy yeah was what like
was scanned let me open up internet yeah
yeah yeah yeah should that loud
conversation yeah just keep both of them
back to back to back
cool so for me uh for me yeah if I'm not
doing it it's because I don't want to do
it it's not actually that's a lie it's
not because I don't want to do it right
it's not like eating up no it's not just
the thing is it's not just about eating
out like in terms of right so there's a
million things right let's get into it
so certain man in this early stages you
can't okay first point is and it's so
random that this keeps coming up in
conversation with like friends I'm
having recently don't trust anything a
guy or anything a girl does in the first
three months okay oh yeah we did speak
about this yeah yeah don't trust a
single thing they do in the first three
months so if I'm her and she's met a new
bra and this new guy is
they're banging for Rounds yeah he's
eating pom from the back from the side
he's making a knot he bangs her he makes
her not again he is right again he's
doing the most and she's thinking raw
this is a man yeah she walked one in
three months yeah yeah you're still
gonna get a certain percentage of what
we're talking about here but let's see
what he's saying in three months because
he's trying to impress other minute just
like you said 15 year guy he used to do
these things and now he doesn't do it
no offense if I've been banging you on
off since I was 15 years old yeah I'm
not trying anything I'm gonna try to
impress you yeah yeah yeah that you were
probably My First Bank yeah yeah
and you were my first battle yeah I'm
not doing backflips for you yeah I'm not
doing but the same way that homeboy is
doing backflips for you over there I'm
doing backflips for it next thing yeah
it's like it's been 15 years what do you
want from me it's a long time so it
depends like yeah if you want to be with
him for the rest of your life and this
is calm for you
um cool and just keep on sightings if
you want to keep sightings but if it
yeah definitely bring it up 100 even if
it's just a case of just like maybe you
don't need all the bells and whistles
that homeboy is giving you on the side
maybe if you're just trying to not
definitely bring it up definitely
definitely bring it up
um but yeah he's not gonna when you
bring it up just be warned he's never
gonna get back to what he was when he
was in the early early stages 15 years
old he was doing all of course he was
hungry yeah and um maybe maybe this is
man this is a hot take I'm just gonna
say maybe remind him a little bit that
you're sought after okay because if I've
been banging you on off since I was 15
what I think is no one else wants you
um
no one else wants you you keep coming
back after 15 years bro I'm either that
guy yeah I'm either him yeah yeah or
you're not her yeah I'm really her why
you got no one why does no one want you
bro yeah yeah yeah from year 10 till now
from year 10 till now you're still on my
doorstep not yeah I mean I'll take it
but I'll take it yeah yeah so maybe
remind him that doesn't matter that I
want now yeah make sure you let him know
you're really her yeah you have to let
nothing really hurt and then yeah your
asshole's gonna get devoured score your
thoughts
um I agree bro at the end of the day if
if you're not reminding him one
um if you are not bringing it up about
the fact that listen you're just eating
my box so you can slide it in you're not
eating you're not stupid yeah add facts
I'm not stupid yeah I'm not stupid are
you eating the box for you or eating the
box for me which one is it yeah do you
like to pleasure me or do you just wanna
Force this thing yeah it is that's not
what sex is for me yeah it's an
experience experience for me and we used
to have that I'm trying to bring that
back listen you have to be honest
especially I don't think
I can I don't think I can know someone
for a decade and a half and not be
completely honest with them you know I
mean especially if they're my sexual oh
God especially if I've got it in my head
that we're not going anywhere exactly
certainly so we need to spice it up yeah
if you're my sexual partner for a decade
and a half I'm being open and honestly
yeah I'm telling you any and everything
facts whether you listen or not is up to
you but I'm gonna be open and honest
with everything I feel and all my
emotions so yeah your best bet is just
tell him you have to tell him whether
you keep your sneaky link on the side is
down to you but you should definitely
definitely tell him how you feel and why
you feel the way you feel because at the
end of the day everyone deserves to be
everyone deserves a not yeah everyone
everyone's enough everybody got to get
theirs boy facts and you've not been
getting yours from your main so that's
why you're deviating to the next thing
but yeah man have the conversation tell
him how you feel and just go from there
yeah because sometimes this is what as
well sometimes for certain man sex is
not really sometimes sex is just a means
to an end and sometimes like
girls ah this is Juicy let's actually
get into it because sometimes yeah
listen yeah this is this is inside
baseball this is backstage stuff that
doesn't really talk about
girls see how girls are like mainly four
player
and guys
on the whole
we just see and we want to bang
if you want like but guys like foreplay
2 but not in the same way girls in
foreplay so girls need foreplay in order
to get going so like we're talking like
once we're in bed it's lips lips
it's slow stuff then we're just doing
some some light touching a bit of
fingering now a woman we're warming up
we're warming up we're warming up where
Madam don't necessarily need that
warm-up but if you want a man that's
doing the most we need to not
necessarily we need to knock down this
is okay this is this is not early days
because honeymoon period I can knock
three four out in a day
um but like I can knock them out in a
day yeah yeah yeah yeah but like
long-term relationship stuff
the guy's version of foreplay is the
Long play like I'm talking about today
so like if we are like maybe we're going
for dinner or something like that yeah
like I need to sexualize the I need to
sexualize you today yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah today because if we're just
cooking in the bed if I've known you for
15 years and you just want to get
started going in bed I promise you
um given a little bit of this yeah a
little bit of this I'm in there yeah and
then we're out and I'm out I'm gonna
sleep yeah because that has got to work
tomorrow yeah yeah but I need to
sexualize you today yeah I know that
today bro and I need to be thinking you
need to be doing little bits and Bobs I
can't wait
yeah yeah yeah yeah tell me from at
breakfast big man hurry home tonight
yeah hurry at home tonight
and then when you finally free up to me
because when I get home I'm I'm running
behind you yeah yeah and you're like
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
when you're saying stop you're still
pushing about it
there you go
biting that leg Yeah
I'm lying trying to stop and this is me
still trying to get that yeah that quick
clap yeah and you're like
she turns around looks you in the eye
looks up at you looks you know I
gradually go slips you and walks off I'm
solid brother I'm sort of thinking I
need to bang this woman yes I have to
yes and you know you're not letting me
get near you yeah yeah yeah and I'm
thinking when's it's gonna pop bro I'm
starving your your tool is going to be
Tangled tingling tingling my boxes are
soaked that preset is everything I'm
drenched
wet wet as they say I'm wet
ah when I'm shopping
yeah pre-seize everyone thinking boy ah
one touch and it's gone one touch and
it's gone so when I finally make it
upstairs and you're in the bed ready
playing with something toys ah
everything all those candles on
I promise you now you're gonna get the
your box
again
you're not because you're desirable
yeah so don't if you're just trying to
yeah if we're doing a long thing and
I've been in there yeah we've banged 3
000 times minimum you can't get it
cooking in the bed and expect me to do
the most because I'm tired I'm tired and
I'm I was gonna say bored I'm not bored
I know so I'm still trying to clap but
this is all I've been here before yeah
when it's a new team yeah no wonder he's
doing the most facts no wonder he is
doing the most because he's excited both
of you excited he does not have this
before you're both very very excited
because it's something new something
fresh you don't know what his routine is
like you know when the girls know their
man's routine or vice versa so yeah yeah
don't move to the position I was going
to move to you in because you just know
that's what I'm gonna do because I'll
walk out I'll walk out
if you know my third move as a back shot
don't get ready for the back yeah wow
and you think you're moving her but then
you twist that shoulder and the shoulder
already starts moving and you just you
just miss her like that and you're like
she thinks I'm predictable she's telling
me to my face I'm predictable that's
hilarious yeah that can never run but
then once yeah be desirable yeah that's
a that's a very good make me starve
that's a good answer yeah because then
when it's time to eat
um yeah I hope that answers your
question I hope it does bro I hope that
helps yeah um right I have a thread
today okay okay A little interesting one
um so I seen this on Instagram okay
and this is an interesting style so the
Titleist thread is what are you
convinced people are pretending to enjoy
I saw that but I never read the comments
yeah yeah yeah what what are you
convinced people are pretending to enjoy
and I'm just gonna bang these one out
fam straight off the top sparkling water
facts delete it that tastes like static
in fact it tastes disgusting why would
you drink Sparkling Water [__] what
is the worst possible thing bro that's
just static and fuzz yeah it's dead fuzz
is right yes it's zero worst drink it
can't hydrate you either yeah it can't
it can't impossible I'm choking on that
pause pause I'm choking on that it's all
zeros and one it's all non-binary I
don't know bro I hate it right bro this
one's controversial but everyone
secretly knows Ray and Neff
Ray and Naf people are conv I'm
convinced people are pretending to draw
a rainf yeah God no I hate rain nothing
wholesome brand but yeah
it doesn't taste it's amazing it's a lot
it's intense you have to love alcohol to
love Ryan nephews
what's that
that says
wow wow fam pretending to enjoy their
friend's success wow that's an OP from
the job bro wow I'm guessed you're doing
so well for yourself
I'm gassed you're doing so well for
yourself ah bro that's so true as well
it's true damn man it is true and the
thing is as well is like hmm have I ever
pretended to enjoy a friend's success
impossible Jay yeah that person is your
friend yeah I couldn't get the words
that person isn't your friend it's
impossible yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
nah yeah nah it's impossible it is
bro this one's this is this is a digger
Ellis
what what you convinced people pretended
to enjoy there's someone with someone
called me that cold sloppy overnight
porridge
when I found out it went in the fridge
yeah I'm speaking are you sure dude
they're banging they're not banging bro
I'll bring one in for you next time
Ellis listen to me I promise you're not
putting out my mouth cold soppy porridge
from the fridge it can't be bad it
doesn't sound bad it is because people
put like seeds and [__] in it as well
I promise
I don't care no bro I don't care bro
that's foolish it's just not nice it's
disgusting yeah fine next one up love
Island
I am convinced people are pretend to
enjoy love Island because like I've said
I've seen one episode and I will never
watch another one listen um I don't
think people pretend to love to love
love Island I think people just hate
people that are on social media
especially Twitter just hate missing out
yeah and they don't gossip they do that
I have to double down yeah yeah watch
Love Island that's also true I will
watch live item for the ghosts exactly
when people say there's juicy juicy
squeezy squeeze on there I want that
that's it the only episode I've ever
watched I saw them doing doing up
challenges and I was like this is the
worst television I've seen
it's the worst tattoo and they were
doing up slow-mos yeah and they were
like sliding through Bubbles and stuff I
was like this is almost television I've
seen the challenges all the challenges
to do always cringy but it's all the
stuff that happens in The Villa that
Twitter goes off on about that's what
they love all the juice so yeah I think
people
quite watch it because they want to be
invested and are involved in the Twitter
conversations that are happening people
just want to be involved in the Twitter
conversations like between eight and
nine or whenever or nine and ten they
want to be the best blowing up they want
to be involved yeah so they have to
watch I'm I yeah it's one of them ones
is luckily I'm not really on Twitter and
secondly I just yeah I've not got into
it ever yeah yeah if I got into it once
and then peaked a little comfortable I'd
be like oh that's facts yeah yeah oh
that's facts okay okay okay okay that's
what we said people message me daily to
watch it and do a rundown I've not
touched this new season I touched last
season I didn't even finish it because
it was just it was under decline dead
bro I'm not watching it um I remember I
read a stat that said
in the episode one of this season had a
million less viewers than last season oh
wow a million that's poor a million
people less watched this year but I can
see why but what I've also heard is that
this season is popping more than last
season in terms of like quality of
content or actual viewers
I just said I don't know about viewers
just heard it's more juicy really
there's more controversy so I feel like
they've I feel like maybe the producers
have like up the ante just because they
know they're full controversy now I'm
intrigued I don't know what you're
talking about I don't know I don't
I've not seen any episode damn any but I
don't know I'm about to switch my entire
mind
hey
but I hate as well on there it's a lot
to watch it's a lot first of all it's
too much it's like four or five episodes
a week that's ridiculous yeah I think
it's six I think the only day they're
doing a show is Saturday there's six
episodes a week and I'm the hour each
roughly this is outrageous stuff I'm not
watching that for a month I think yeah
month or six months that's too much bro
and I hate I'm not into um
I'm not everyone has like uh I hate
Cockney Essex slang okay I don't like it
okay I don't like it okay so I was on
because they've first of all props
they've got their own Tick Tock I don't
know if they had it last year love
Island and it pops up on my feed the
other day so they're just doing like
bite-sized clips and I was like I'm fair
this is how what I would if I was gonna
digest it this is how I digest it so
wait that with the clips they're showing
content from the actual show yeah oh
yeah they're actually showing content
from the show oh interesting so this is
how I would watch it if I was gonna
watch it it's very very smart move okay
um
but when I when I was talking about I
saw two people having a conversation uh
Jarred me so much because they were like
there's one guy talking about one of the
yachts and then to another chick and it
was like yeah yeah obviously she's a
good looking girl and like she's got I
hate when people say she's got a good
chat I hate when people say she's got
good chat oh he's got a good chat yeah
good bands good chat all that Essex
slang I can't stand it it makes me wanna
oh bro I can't I find it so Butters bro
yeah I find I just can't stand it I
don't know why it just it just it just
it just irks me fair enough when people
say oh yeah they got good chat I'm just
like shut up
fair enough good looking girl good chat
bye
bye no one could no thing could ever
tell me yeah
because I promise you we're not we're
never doing a thing
we're never the last shot you're hearing
from me yeah how would you know yeah
because we're not talking right guys
let's take a very quick break from the
episode I want to talk to you about
couples play I want to talk to you about
solo play I want to talk to you about
lello and I want to talk to you about
the tour three yeah one not two but
three so guys as James said tour three
is all about the pleasure whether it
with your partners or by yourself and
man like me you guys know if you know
you know I like to please I aim to
please so yeah I'm gonna make sure I'm
gonna make sure I'm gonna use this and
make sure I please so guys you're only
going to use this
if you recognize that technology is part
of our everyday lives okay if you're
shying away from technology in big big
23 yeah it's not for you you're not
really on it like that but if you're
like us and you like technology you like
to optimize then it's the it's the thing
for you that's the one if you want to
use the tour 3
special yellow toy uninterrupted make
sure you download the app as well yes
sir it's got eight powerful pleasure
settings guys so we're buzzing this
thing up to eight yeah and we're not
nothing
you can hear that that Vibe I can see it
you can see it shaking shaking yeah
yeah okay guys so when you're ready to
jump in hit the link in the description
for 25 off use the code shits and gigs
25 and this includes all lello products
except the Luxe line okay and new
launches okay the tour 23 is in there
shits and gigs 25 click the link in the
description let's go finish lines
busting nuts clapping cheeks let's go
let's get back to the episode thanks
guys let's take a quick break ladies
listen up there's a lot of you listening
right now you like the smooth melatones
of your man's voices over here so listen
close and pay attention right we all
know it's hot girl summer we already
know it is you don't need to remind us
but what kind of summer is your man
having
your man have him [__] if your man
isn't participating in smooth sack
summer then what's he doing about facts
what is he actually doing we're over
here we'll just smoothie smoothie sacks
that's how I roll that is how I roll too
yeah but when it sticks to my leg I'm
proud I'm proud bro cause it's smooth
smooth so when you're playing in the
Summer sun make sure he escaped from
pubes to bum guys
that's right it's the summer to keep his
balls cool while still looking hot with
manscapes they are the leaders in below
the waist grooming and they're making
sure we all have a ball this summer by
giving our pants Partners everything
they need to stay fresh dive head first
into smooth sack summer and head on over
to manscape.com and if you want 20 off
plus free shipping use our exclusive
code which is s n g Sierra November golf
let's head back to the episode say less
all right cool what is it love Island ah
facts right what you convinced people to
pretending to enjoy this one's sweetened
me J Hassan Drake who told you
split in the audience on this one yeah
I'm not gonna lie the first time I heard
it I was like
Drake doesn't fit this sound yeah he
doesn't he doesn't more and more and
more and more I listen to it yeah the
vibey and vibey and vibrary again I
don't like it I played it like four
times I don't like it yeah but you've
heard it I've heard it quite a bit I
shouldn't have to hear it quite yeah
don't get me wrong I know but it just
grows on me it just grows on me and I
feel like once you get past like the
first eight bars of Drake's verse um
as it goes into the other half of it
it's just it flows and it's a Vibe if
you listen to it in the car the sun's
out it's a Vibe it sounds like you're
giving like so many yeah I know I know
don't get me wrong I would have much
referred it if it was like J house and
NSG they would have made a summer back
yeah yeah yeah
I am I think I'm over compensating
because it's them too and I want to
enjoy the song I think what ends up
happening with this kind of stuff
because it always happens if Drake every
time a UK artist has a collab with Drake
I think we're just happier for the
artist than we offer the song Facts
we're just happier that he's you've made
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Jazz didn't
make songs in [__] years and has come
out he's got his track with Drake Thank
well done yeah yeah yeah yeah good job
facts yeah yeah banging very nice that
makes sense um but yeah I think whenever
he jumps on with people same with dude
with heady one as well
sometimes undeserved
mature and undesired the premature is
the word too soon bro wow next one what
do you convinced people pretend to enjoy
motherhood
yeah yeah
yeah I can imagine next up anal
yep yep yep that's jokes yep that's
jokes pram this one is me to a t talking
to work colleagues during lunch oh
brother I couldn't stand it I didn't
pretend to enjoy it at all that is
hilarious depending on where you work
and where you're actually having your
lunch but understandable well leave me
alone yeah I'm just trying to this is
literally my only free time yeah shut up
leave me alone bro it's literally my
only 30 today bro I remember my brother
used to say he used to eat in his car
just to be left alone and he used to go
to his car and eat lunch and I've done
that a couple times but that made me sad
yeah yeah that made me sad I said that
because you can't I can't witness you I
can't walk past you yeah I see you
eating in your car at 12 30. no no no I
couldn't I would knock on your door
what's going on are you meant to be in
work why are you eating your car bro pop
it up in that lunchbox in the car nah I
couldn't see that do you not have
friends Darren that's the first thing I
think so your friends yeah someone could
ask me that I'll say obviously not look
where I am fine my friends are at home
my friends aren't here
I wish they were but they're not yeah
yeah oh bro being a stepdad wow
yeah say this yeah this wants me to a t
i could have written this one myself
halloumi cheese bro I hate holy I can't
stand this the saltiest thing bro it's
salty and chewy and rubbery and awful
I'm convinced people are trying to [__]
when they order us separately at Nando's
is this not deserving of a separate
order me bites or let me sticks whatever
it's called whatever bro it's not
deserving bro yeah yeah oh in fact
exercise
I'm not enjoying exercises a minute
family I've been keeping up with it I'm
really not enjoying it it's a mental
thing yeah if my mind isn't for it I
could not go for weeks do you know what
I mean weeks James I'm not even
exaggerating
I just have that mental switch and I'm
just not going yeah bro
um I want to be honest with that and
it's
at this point in my life I'm so grateful
to be over 30. yeah because I can't take
weeks off yes
[Music]
and that's the only thing at this point
in my life that's getting me there okay
because bro I I honestly I'm not
enjoying it guys I'm just gonna confide
in you man I'm really not enjoying it at
the minute and I don't know what to do
I'm just gonna keep wearing baggies oh
so you don't see [__] I'm really I don't
know what Ellis how are you getting on
because you've been in there I [__]
love it mate yeah that's tell me let's
get a massive Buzz man tell me that's
the endorphins
for me I swear pool day is the [__]
best day full day is good yeah man I
love it obviously
um you I think you will learn to enjoy
legs in a few years but the issue is I
don't know the names obvious the stuff I
do Luke demo I just do it you tell me
what you do give us support give us your
pool day now it's different we mix it up
that's another thing as well I I same
with anything I get really bored very
quickly so I started running
[Music]
we do
where you sat down seated row yeah yeah
did you do bent over rows okay continue
that's Advanced yeah no idea um yeah
that's the thing it's very basic because
obviously I'm still starting out
um but you feel good afterwards yeah man
I feel [__] amazing I I love like
except for I don't like legs I hate legs
obviously those people hate legs I don't
mind I quite like doing the squats
that's like a new thing so yeah yeah
Sports is sick yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah so everything you learn is
like yeah fantastic yeah you learn how
your body works
getting them stronger I'm jealous I'm
training stuff I've never like you just
never think you didn't know muscles I
did one with um with like the cables
yeah uh we do one where you literally go
like that across yeah yeah yeah like the
most painful thing like 2.5
second block
posterior adult thing yes it's sick I
[__] love it my favorite thing to
train is uh is it triceps yeah yeah I
love doing them with the head yeah yeah
I love it absolutely
[__] jealous bro like I said probably
because I'm new most likely I don't know
sometimes it is good bro I just need
something else I need I even need a
trainer partner obviously I've been
doing PT PT's cool train the partner's
really good I've been going with Jackson
yeah yeah especially if someone's like
similar strength to you and stuff like
that and you push each other and you go
through motivational it's so good bro
it's really really good but like
damn I need something yeah because I'm
bored at the minute and I do go through
phases like this but they've recently
they've been coming a lot faster yeah
like you it used to be like every couple
of years I'd have like a month or two
where I'm like I can't bother and then
I'll get back into it recently it's been
like one month on one month off yep same
so I would have a great month yeah and
then we probably like we'd go on holiday
I would have a busy ass week we'd flop
not train and then our next week I'm
just like oh maybe I'll cycle maybe I'll
do one exercise here and then just the
week bro I never thought I'd say this
maybe I might try CrossFit or something
there's so many different exercises and
so many different things that we
probably don't do on our day today or
every time we train that keeps it fresh
and keeps it new and keeps us interested
so I hear what you're saying about the
CrossFit I do actually hear what you're
saying about the CrossFit maybe I'll do
it
I actually do hear what you're saying
I'm not gonna lie because it's it's it's
competitive as well it caused everything
in your body yeah and you you do love to
compete so yeah maybe because yeah it's
a competition for me I love competition
yeah it's good to say maybe you just
need competition yeah let me get into
boxing again or something it's not going
to get me wambra yeah it's true it'll
get you lean yeah yeah
yeah it will get me shredded but it's
not gonna it's not gonna it's not gonna
take the box I need I need to get Wham
yeah maybe because I know my boy Lewis
wants to do CrossFit he always talks
about it
you know what I'm gonna [__] message
him after here I'm like bro and if I say
this just give it a go David Lloyds well
CrossFit I don't know why they do but
now you have to go to a specific
CrossFit place like oh say like they
call it I think they call it box go to
it I'm gonna get DMS first all right
everyone who's listening watching caviar
don't DM me about it I know everything
there is to learn about CrossFit I've
seen all the documentaries I used to be
obsessed with the athletes and
yeah if I don't care I don't care what
you want to say yeah you're not going to
convince me anymore and if you DM me I
just won't go yeah I don't deal with
pressure well so anyone who's like oh
yeah you should definitely do it because
and all the other haters are like no
don't do it because you're gonna get
injured both of you shut up I'm not
listening to any of you so don't waste
your data don't message me about this
[__] [__] but I'm gonna mess with my
boy and say let's give it a go and then
go from there because their men are
obviously they're on all the gear yeah
but their man are Wham and they're
shredded strong bro oh vomit yeah
they're strong as far and it's it's mad
because they have like obviously they go
in there and have to work out the day
right so you basically this is what I
know about CrossFit okay you go in there
it's a workout other day and I'm like
this is what we're doing we'll do a
[__] Linda or whatever the [__] it
was like it's gonna be like 20 snatches
[__] 100 burpees
um
this many squats and then this and you
just have to do it yeah it doesn't
matter if you want bigger legs bigger
shoulders big enough in you're doing
what they tell you to do and you need to
get it done and then they'll practice
certain lifts and then like you need to
practice like hands down walks and all
this kind of [__] that you have to do
and it's kind of cool man and then you
do like their stupid like Kippy pull-ups
I hate the pull-ups they do but like you
learn how to do like muscle ups and [__]
like that yeah yeah and you'll be doing
all sorts man and then like you're just
getting strong there's a lot of
calisthentics bro yeah you get bear
strong and then you end up eating more
drinking more and brawl just like sounds
kind of cool because I'm guys I'm
really bored of exercise at the minute
it's so jarring you've been doing uh Jiu
Jitsu though right
um well recently
because I swear there was a point not
that long ago you were getting back into
it and I just went with Timmy for fun Oh
I thought you were getting yeah Tammy
Twisted him up yeah if he's listening he
probably is Twisted him up
let him know that it's not a gaming yeah
Daddy knows what he's doing yeah yeah
yeah that's true yeah but now we had a
good time
um yeah we had we had a good time and um
it was good and I spotted with a couple
after he left I spotted a couple of
other people Twisted them up as well and
I was like I've actually still got it
yeah and then I just I just drove him
and never went back yeah but I'm not
interested in get back into Jujitsu that
much it's cool but it's also just like I
get obsessed with it and it takes over
my life and it's just like yeah it's not
it's not a place I want to be for I I
have bad back and bad neck from it like
every time okay
um but yeah man damn maybe CrossFit I'm
looking for something
hey hey anyway you never know let me
finish this red real quick
yeah same what you convinced people are
pretending to enjoy yeah we just
finished exercise facts coming out two
nights in a row impossible [__] that's
possible impossible oh God bro this one
is for me facts Aki bro
hockey Akins like I can selfish oh fam
fam rattle yeah yeah facts Aki sucks
I'm sorry guys I'm Caribbean too Aki
sucks bro I hate it I hate the
culmination yeah
dish don't ever give it to me I hate it
was so rattled but yeah I hate Aki next
one I hate even more beer oh [__] sucks
bro I hate this I can't stand beer yeah
bro this was sweet to me someone
commented cartoned coconut water it
tastes like it's already a bit in
someone's mouth
[Laughter]
wow that's disgusting not specific last
one this is me to a tea boil potatoes
you don't have all potatoes four
potatoes pennies
this are pennies bro to be fair to be
actually fair I don't I can't be the
last time I had a boy potato bro but
with confidence I actually don't eat
boiled potatoes just a straight boiled
potatoes bro how do you stop it tastes
like metal it's disgusting I've actually
not had a Bob's tone ages oh if I'm
trying to have an Irish mum you all have
Audible potatoes
I grew up in hell
fam boiled potatoes was my mum's goat
too
just spoiled not fried not oven no no
butter based nothing oil potatoes and
Jackie potatoes I used to love a jacket
potatoes
I love the jacket unless I have beans in
that [__] yeah beans and cheese yeah
yeah
just smothered it's just like Colossians
that was all right but I didn't love it
I just ate it bro I just didn't like the
skin I couldn't eat this skin yeah same
the skin on the jacket is bad yeah yeah
but boiled potato is the worst thing
known to matter unless you're gonna
butter base that [__] and season it
maybe some chives on top give me
something I can work with give yourself
my mom used to just boil and put on a
plate nah that's heinous
bro I'm always a boy to put on a plate
that's heinous yeah she used to make
he's angry bro is he angry on a hot
summer's day yeah I think I've said
something similar before on a hot
summer's day when your boys are playing
out yeah ah I will come all the way home
starving yeah starving a sweat yeah
pasta oh pasta salad
with meat yeah yeah I'm a man your facts
my mom I tell them I'm gonna put a plate
in front of me it would have four
potatoes straight out of pot yeah salad
mixed with tuna oh God and eggs boiled
eggs
it was a prison meal oh that sounds like
a prison meal what is it she says too
hot for pasta what does that mean what
does that mean you might tell me your
nervous heart bro people drink tea in
the morning every morning regardless of
the words but she always say it's too
hot for that that rich deep food bro
that that food you're gurning for it's
too hot for that that means have some
boiled eggs and tuna and leaves and
[__] boiled potatoes nah bro taking
the piss I used to scream into my pillow
bro I'd make the pasta myself yeah I
went to she goes better make the pasta
I'd move it around a plate and dive into
the cookies
I'd Shuffle that [__] around the blade
dive straight into the cookies that's
all I had yeah that's all I had left in
the house but I was starting to go to
bed it's like rolling in pain
man refused to eat is my brother I used
to go rolling in pain bro I hated that
meal oh and she used to do little bits
of ham on there as well
should you get like sandwich ham tear it
up and put that and like just put the
garnish it in the salad a bit yeah on
the salad bit tuna all of it was cold
nah the whole thing was cold because
it's too hot outside apparently nah bro
give me the pasta I want a spaghetti
bolognese I'd come back from a hot
summer's day and eat pounded yam and
slumped so if I hate yam but I if I
liked it that would be perfect will
slump you yam yam reminds me of I love
you yesterday's roast potatoes I heated
up in the microwave
that's what the texture of yam reminds
me of
it charged me bro yesterday's roast I
put back in the microwave oh I would
I know exactly what you mean in terms of
like the the texture but you've probably
had like
tough yam before I've had all kinds I've
had your yam and that's what it tastes
like whatever made you
yamani yeah yeah with corned beef [__]
probably yeah probably yeah yeah that's
exactly what it tastes like so don't
tell me what kind of yam I've had
I forgot about that I remember it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah bro I've had all
kinds of yum it all it all gives me the
same Vibe bro I hate yam but if I liked
it yeah on a hot summer's day I want to
come back to that yeah yeah that'll
slump you yeah bro all my friends were
having good dinners you were having
salad and I was having salad salads and
cold foods well the whole plate was cold
nah bro nah bro because I remember she'd
put she'd put the plate in the fridge
with the cling film wait for me to eat
it that [__] wasn't touching a
microwave I'd have to take it out take
the clean form off and eat like that
damn
I hate I hated that that's probably what
why you double down on cooking yeah yeah
because I needed to experience stuff I
need to experience stuff bro yeah I love
my mom but damn I hated that damn I
hated that sometimes my stepdad will
cook and I'd be gas yeah I hate him as a
as a human I hate it as a human but
sometimes they cook I'll be God that's
something different yeah cook slippery
wings
oh when he got he used to show off yeah
yeah so we'd have all sorts and I'll be
there
give me more yeah oh bro but yeah [__]
that's hilarious yeah sometimes I come
home to oxtail stew or something just
just gassed okay it would fill me up and
I'll sleep like a man
are you up today on all anime not all so
um one up I'm haven't watched this
week's episode of Hell's Paradise apart
from that I'm up to date okay still
haven't touched demons there they've had
the finale and everything right now
someone dmes is a finale is lit 96 51
minutes really yeah okay cool I've been
saying that every week that I'm gonna do
it tonight do it tonight I haven't done
it tonight so I'm just gonna stop saying
it
um I've watched have you started the
other one yet what's the other one the
Ashley whatever no no whatever Disney no
no no no no I'm not I haven't watched
any more of that since we last spoke but
again that's gang so no anime wise I'm
not up to date on anything okay fair
enough um I've I'm up today on house
Paradise uh good episode
um I think Finland Saga came out
yesterday I don't think I've seen the
finale yet
um what's it say I think I'm like two or
three behind
it's because they were moving because
the last thing I saw was Thor Finn
letting that man go
and saying I need to go oh I know we're
talking about oh he went water for some
people was like I'm gonna go see King
canuta yeah yeah yeah we're gonna yeah
I'm gonna go see King canoe that's all I
saw yeah so I just assumed he was gonna
run through everyone
that's what I thought but yeah it's so
lackluster bro Fitness nuggets [__]
[__] this year man I just don't I don't
know why they would go from such an arms
House season one to such a storyline
poetic whatever in season yeah season
one was so wam bro it was one of the
greatest ones I've seen at that time
yeah yeah same at that time I was like
wow this year and every time they give
us a peek of what might be yeah they
just the next episode
yeah I'm hoping I'm really hoping mapper
just did this season too for the poetic
nonsense I didn't want to do and for
season three if they do a season three
it just bangs well obviously at this
right I'll be surprised if it gets green
lit for season three because this is and
then like they're just dragging stuff
out like with the whole flipping um when
home girl's husband died yes
that lasted like an entire episode yeah
yeah yeah it took ages when he was like
on the little thing that lasted an
episode and I was like this has to be a
joke you're not wasting my time like
this extending everything for no reason
um do you know what I see a couple Clips
off on Tick Tock once in a while and I'm
like God I need to catch up it's Black
Clover it's funny you just said that
because I was thinking when you said
that I was thinking about the Black
Clover movie that they've just dropped
on Netflix oh I saw the trailer a couple
days ago and they're not decent I'm not
gonna lie they're not decent but for the
life of me I don't know where I slapped
to Black Clover okay I have no idea
where I stopped in Black Clover I don't
I don't I don't remember where I stopped
um but I remember where I thought was
kind of hard
what was the last thing you remember
so the last thing I remember were around
the sea the bit where like the
I can't describe it so like
people have started to get kind of like
people got taken over a lot of the
captains and stuff got taken okay okay
okay okay okay okay yeah um and I
remember it was the the captain that
does all the vines yes she got taken
over by the elves isn't it they're elves
right yes so the elves possessed people
yep and then it was
um Captain yummy yummy yeah yeah it was
fighting
home girl
that's kind of what I remember I
remember the king got murked off by the
main elf right
yes yes yes I think
um I think we're I think I'm ahead of
you but I think we're in similar arcs
okay so around about there somewhere is
kind of what I remember if anyone knows
ruffy what episode we're on just putting
up oh yeah put in the comments and I'll
actually we'll jump back on the job
because that's so that's something we
can binge I watched I watched episode I
saw a clip on Tick Tock the other day of
the female fire one you know the the
three the siblings there's a sister a
brother and another brother the one with
the redhead yeah so his sibling his
sister okay yeah yeah because there's a
younger one who's on that team as well
okay yeah younger boy yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes okay his sister okay
um because they always say that um if
she wanted she would be captain and not
him because she's wow forget bro so yeah
she's got one sharp tooth that pokes out
of her mouth here anyway I saw
everything on Tick Tock of her just
doing the most I think it must be even
though like what's happening now and I
was like it's gonna have to be yes ma'am
say this um but now I'm not really up to
date on anything else
gang the last the last episode is good
last episode's good yeah yeah okay sick
yeah demon stays heavy as well obviously
obviously all right you've got thread
for us yeah I do have a thread right
um so this thread is
um of the shade bar so resonance
um as the energy from DLT motor Branch
dies down sex relationship blogger olini
has asked for the ladies to spill some
Saucy secrets about their trip so yeah I
saw one I saw I read one of these
heinous and close the app
so there's like a couple a couple
confessions sent to her so I'm gonna
read them out
um hey oloni I didn't have a threesome
or my first lesbian experience
unfortunately but the alcohol was
flowing and I was ready to hoe out so I
ended up having sex with six different
guys over six days that I was there
on one of the last days I Banks three
guys in one day the sex was so good I
got my ass ate squared all over one guy
sheets and banged in a hotel with a
mirror on the ceiling honestly I would
do it all again
Jesus bro
yeah that Malta was a movie apparently
hey I was going to take this to my grave
but why
I have to live my truth so on the second
day I had group sex with three other
girls and two guys it was really good
and I'd love to do it again if the
opportunity ever presents itself the two
guys [__] me together one in my ass
and the other in my mouth as one of the
girls ate me out I definitely do it
again I know you'll see this I'll
definitely do it again they put the name
across it out I know you'll see this
call me back
imagine wow one of the participants
call me back she's just getting air she
wants to do it again I need us again
hi mine is not too much of a wild story
I actually think I found love in DLT
I've met this guy on the I've met this
guy on the day before Oh on the day
before DLT started and it didn't take
him too seriously why he would find me
every day and come and talk to me on
some good vibes amazing contact amazing
eye contact and lots of flirting then on
day two we kissed the whole night missed
out on most of the acts literally
couldn't stop raw just kiss it just lips
oh I can't lips all night bro yeah
that will turn me off
I would be over aroused I'd be bored
afterwards yeah the third lips I'll be
over it because if we're lips and lips
and lips in then we go our separate ways
and I'll see you again when we lips in
we can't go separate ways and then I'll
see you again yeah no you have to do
something else you have to go somewhere
um definitely over it yeah then on the
second night um we kissed the whole
night
um missed out on most of the acts unless
you couldn't stop went to his but
nothing happened besides good music and
good conversation we kept meeting each
other and hanging out with each other's
friends it was so nice and then on the
last day and then the last day a little
bit of this and a little bit of that
happened he lives in a different
European country so I'm currently on my
way to see him for the weekend Oh damn
that escalated quick
Anonymous please I met my friend's
friend a guy on the last day and he was
so cute we flirted a bit and then we
went back then we went to a party I saw
him a few hours later and he took me to
one of the rooms and he ate me out so
good after that we went back to the
party like nothing happened
he just ate the bum and let it go back
he was
suffering after that that's naughty damn
bro was it DLT Malta brunch thing yeah
that was it I didn't even
I did hear about this I was gonna say I
didn't even I didn't even I didn't even
hear I just heard when people were there
yeah I didn't hear the the buzz promo
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I remember I remember the buzz a lot
more last year because I was in Malta I
think the month before it happened and I
was thinking like posters and [__]
but I don't remember the pre Buzz this
year but obviously I remember when
everyone was there yeah I remember when
everyone was there all I saw was like I
remember seeing like one tweet or one
thing or like if you're a man's Immortal
right now sorry yeah or something like
that yeah yeah
um
or like cool Samaritans or something
um and then I was like oh oh okay and I
don't I don't remember the pre Buzz
whatsoever yeah but damn people just
going off
literally it's so mad as well it's only
stuff like this and
um like afro Nation yeah that you'll
hear like black people just lose they're
losing themselves
yeah this is their home
if you're brought if I fancy you in the
UK yeah
that's what they're on that's what
they're on yeah
it's so crazy these jokes that's funny
boy yeah yeah man that's the way they
move that is the way they move right to
finish off you've got a question for us
apparently oh yeah I saw this question
on
I think someone sent this to me on
Instagram but it's on the shade bar so I
read out to you you may have seen I'm
not too sure cool you're offered 50 bags
okay but if you accept it the person you
hate the most in the entire world gets a
hundred bags
every single time you accept the 50 bags
they're gonna get 100 bags the person
you hate the most who do I hate in the
most I don't know who I hate the most in
the world but just imagine it I'm trying
to imagine how much I hate someone
because I don't hate anyone
um okay I can think of it
one person right now I don't know if I'm
thinking of the same person oh you
thinking something for me yeah yeah but
I can't imagine you allow them to get
100 bags
the person I'm thinking of I can't
imagine it James I cannot imagine it I
promise you you're not taking anything
back I promise you if we're thinking
about the same person I'm actually not
taking the 50 bags I'm actually not
taking the money back this is wild bro
wow I'm not taking I know I'm not taking
it we can both be broke together I can't
imagine I've never got to say this the
I'm gonna say the species you've never
got to get a sense because I know it
yeah exactly who you're thinking about
well I hope I don't anyway wow yeah I'm
not I'm not letting them get it yeah I
know you won't let them get 100 bags wow
yeah I actually wouldn't bro
that's mad bro no it's crazy isn't it
um Ellis what about you yeah same thing
I don't really hate it but yeah I would
I would actually you'd take the thing
yeah I would yeah yeah try and think of
something because you're earning more
than them aren't you you get 50 they get
they get 100. I thought they got 10. you
accept the 50 bags they get a hundred oh
that would piss me off
that's what I'm saying no I'd still take
it you take it yeah you can't think of
it I'd have to I'd have to well I mean I
would if I hated them anyway but I'd
have to complete them completely block
them I couldn't see them spending the
money yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I'd have to move country and just delete
social media yeah you can see the insta
stories yeah yeah like wow I stay Rich
yeah
I'd be so I know exactly you're thinking
of and you would be livid
yeah I'll actually it's so petty I
wouldn't I wouldn't do it wouldn't take
it I know it's scary because I'm not
even that kind of guy and for just this
one person I wouldn't do it bro no bro
that's not can you think of anyone I'm
that's what I'm trying to think
I don't know anyone that I've that I I
personally don't hate anyone but I don't
know any single person I feel like I'd
feel some type of way if I take 50. yeah
I can make a hundred I can't think of
anyone for you that off the top of my
head that you would
it wouldn't would you would uh it would
piss you off so much then getting 100
bags not off the Dome no I don't think
so but for you 100 I know yeah there's
only one yeah 100 I know there's only
there's literally only one person that's
not it's Pro does not throw
[Applause]
right anyway guys we're gonna wrap it
there yeah that was juicy woozy as
always head on over to patreon.com shits
and gigs um to catch us on Thursday for
episode
300. yes sir so head on over there now
enjoy and as always guys
[Music]
foreign